[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in mike tannenbaum espn
front office insider former jets gm and
also dolphins executive mike i saw a
couple of days ago where you said aaron
rodgers was being selfish explain
why the timing of this that uh he's
selfish
yeah great to be with you
the salary cap system his decision is
going to impact a lot of his teammates
specifically devonte adams preston smith
cedarian smith a couple other guys as
well
when you look at what drew brees and the
saints said the last four years he was
there dan they had the best worker in
the nfl it's really simple you lower the
cap charges now and you push them out if
he's going to come back and don't get me
wrong and roger should be the highest
play paid player in the game he deserves
whatever he wants but he's being selfish
because until he says i am back they
can't resign some of their players we
just came back from the combine last
night you're already hearing things like
demarcus lawrence being asked to take a
pay cut other players getting deals done
or not
they can't handle their business until
the packers know if roger's gonna be
there and how to structure his contract
why do you think this is taking so much
time that he's truly torn between
staying in green bay and going someplace
else
i think every day that he's not making
decision he's closer to leaving and
here's why like what could he possibly
know on march 8th or 9th that he doesn't
know today you know dan smartly about 10
days ago the packers hired his old
quarterback coach tom clements there's
nothing else that he needs to know if he
was coming back he should say hey fellas
pay me 50 million dollars a year lower
the cap numbers bring everyone back we
saw that with tom brady in tampa bay
every day he doesn't see that i would be
scared to death if i'm the packers and
thinking you know what we're probably
going to have to move on from him and a
whole bunch of other players and we got
to rebuild what's his trade value at
that age
well i think because of what we saw with
tom brady i think it's a minimum of two
first-round picks and probably three you
know if matt stafford one for two i'm
probably if i'm george payton the
general manager of the broncos i'm going
up three first round picks and i'm gonna
be the odds on favorite to represent the
afc in the super bowl next year with
aaron rodgers as my quarterback
if you're denver would you do that if i
said it's going to cost you three first
i was told a long time ago green bay has
so much confidence in their ability to
draft they want picks they don't want
players so if your green bay you get
those picks you give up aaron rodgers if
you have to is that worth it
100 you can't overpay greatness
if you have aaron rodgers for three
years or four years does it really
matter it could cost you an extra first
round pick which by all accounts dan
should be a low pick in the 20s maybe 31
32
so
the day he walks in the building you
have a meaningful chance to win the
championship and by the way again that
gives you about four or five years to
try to draft his replacement as well
i'm also trying to figure out what's
going on in seattle because i feel like
they're quietly shopping russell wilson
and he's got the you know he he can uh
got the uh
trade uh
kicker in there that he can't be traded
he can veto that so
what is what should seattle do i totally
agree they should rebuild if i was
seattle john schneier has done a great
job there as your gm they have the
fourth best team in the nfc west if you
could get multiple first round picks and
to me where it all lines up is
philadelphia go get their three ones
philadelphia with russell wilson has a
chance to win the nfc east and now if
you're seattle you could rebuild because
right now if you're there with russell
wilson you're looking up at not only the
rams but the 49ers and arizona made the
playoffs for calla murray so if i'm then
we had a great run with russell but now
is the time to restart
yeah but i wonder if that's the place
that russ would want to go
it now i think philadelphia is a lot
better than
what people think
i just don't know
um if that's that that's a team that
russ would want to go to and would
seattle let him go to the nfc
no that's totally fair now with that
said the other place i think is
fascinating to me
is pittsburgh you have a championship
head coach you got a championship
defense and the pitch i would make if i
was pittsburgh is hey look our defense
is as good as what tampa's was two years
ago tom brady came down we won a
championship you bring russell wilson in
with chase claypole naji harris and that
defense they have a chance to win a
championship and dan this is really hard
for us to say but pittsburgh has to
figure out how are they going to close
the gap with none other than the
cincinnati bengals yeah
but how do you quietly shop somebody
mike
that's how we got brett favre when i was
at the jets that's your job you got to
be a great listener you got to call
every team all the time and you have to
say hey is russell wilson available and
tell us what the bill is you're when
you're dealing with guys like russell
wilson and aaron rodgers
there's not a ton of negotiations it's
more of like here's the bill do you want
to pay it and again based on my
experience dan
you pay bills you can't overpay
greatness in terms of quarterback we
just came back from the combine there's
really not a lot of answers there this
year and
there's about at least 12 teams that
need a quarterback if i could get wilson
or rogers i'm not letting the other team
get off the phone but when you called
the packers about brett favre
get take me into those discussions how
does it work
well he really want to go to tampa bay
and pay for john gruden at the time and
wanted nothing to do with going to new
york in the northeast so we actually
spent a lot of time convincing him that
where we were there was farms and he
could go hunting in fact i said brent if
you don't hunt every single tuesday your
day off i'm gonna find you there will be
mandatory hunting and fishing as a new
york jet um and we just kept trying to
understand what his concerns were
because green bay ironically with aaron
rodgers sitting there knew they were in
great shape at the quarterback position
and what we had going for us was
they really wanted him in the afc more
than the nfc so that that really helped
our advantage and again
fast forward to today dan if i'm sitting
there as the packers i would much prefer
to trade aaron rodgers to the denver
broncos than the 49ers or any other team
in the nfc
yeah but i also wonder if green bay knew
what they had in jordan love would they
be going through any of this right now
i think green bay had the right strategy
and poorly executed and what i mean by
that is two years ago they said hey you
know what we gotta be prepared for aaron
rodgers graduating and what happened was
they traded a fourth round pick whoops
they traded a fourth round pick to go up
and get jordan love they have more
questions than answers with him and if i
was them i would just keep adding one
and that's what the great ron wolf did
matt hausabet mark brunell aaron brooks
all those quarterbacks were developed
under brett favre they need that same
mindset because the only grade you
really could give jordan love dan is a
great incomplete but they have to keep
that mindset of keep adding another
quarterback would you rather have aaron
rodgers for three years or russell
wilson for five
rogers for three because i think he's
the best player on the planet and again
if we were running a team dan we'll keep
looking for his replacement but will you
have a chance to win a championship it's
hard to say no to that
would you rather have rogers for one
year or brady for one year
ooh
probably brady i got 20 years of scar
tissue
who would you take dan
for one year i would take rogers
um
i think he can do more with less i think
brady when it's structured when it's
like
he he has
the right people in the right place i
think rogers can make things happen i
don't think tom makes those things
happen
um all things equal
that tom gets to pick his team and aaron
gets pick his team i'd probably take tom
but you know you don't get to always do
that
let's spice it up a little bit i'd
rather have tom brady at his salary and
his
lesser demands economically than rogers
as his because if we have time we can
bring back a lot more of the band and
okay
uh how much is tom going to cost you
we'd pay for about 25 26 billion in
tampa where rogers will probably take
probably double that if if mahomes is at
45 i think rogers if he plays will be
north of 50. yeah and i think that's
fair when you bring in the money but um
do you think tom brady's done
no i don't you know why he could have
told the entire planet when he was on
with jim gray that i am done
unequivocally and i think if you cut tom
brady in half dan what's going to ooze
out of them is a world-class competitor
and you're a great dad i like to think
i'm a good dad
you could take your kids to school and
that's all well and good but
it's tom brady like how many times can
you take the garbage out to the end of
the driveway right i mean even as long
as the driveway as he has like at some
point right
guys still playing at a high level
how do you pursue tom brady if you're
the niners
oh that's easy i am relentless i am
saying this is about your legacy this is
your hometown
and we'll talk to tampa bay you tell
them that you're not going to play there
i lived this unfortunately because what
happened was far was like look i want to
play one more year and i don't want to
play here anymore it worked out for us
at the jets because we had just hired
rex ryan we wanted to draft somebody to
build with rex we we got fortunate
worked out we drafted sanchez won a
whole bunch of games together
but if i was the 49ers i would call up
joel laser the owner of the buccaneers
and just say hey he's not playing there
anymore
we we want to sign him for you know one
more year and we'll give you something
because if not he's just going to rot
away on your reserve retired list so why
not get at least something for him and
then at the right time have tom put some
pressure on and that could be more of a
july conversation to be candid
yeah but it you know bruce aryan said
it's bad for business if all of a sudden
you're letting tom kind of dictate what
goes on here
yeah what's worse for business bruce is
if you get nothing for a guy that says
he wants to play but he just wants to
play for his hometown so um
it could get really sticky and again i
actually lived at dan i thought through
those imaginations of like we may tell
brett he can't go anyplace else but i
was just thinking like at the end of the
day if the guy doesn't want to be there
you're really stopping progress of your
own organization so at some point cut
your losses get what you can and move on
because at some point either kyle trask
or blaine gabbert someone's going to be
the guy for them in tampa bay and if tom
wakes up on july 4th and said hey you
know these carpools are a little bit too
much for me and i want to play for my
hometown i think it'd be hard for tampa
to stop that all right we have a bet
here uh paulie my producer thinks that a
quarterback is selected
the first 13 picks of this draft
the over under is 13 and a half now any
quarterback is going to go in the top 13
picks
where do you want to uh weigh in on that
i'm going to take the under i was there
um there's a lot more questions than
answers this year and with that said if
you and i again we're having a
conversation in three years i think
kenny pickett will be a decent starter i
think malik willis is super intriguing
because he's really well built he just
needs a little polish and i think
they'll be drafted but i think it's
lower in the teens at the earliest oh so
you're taking the over so there's not a
quarterback selected in the first 13 oh
sorry yeah yeah i bet under like lower
the round but
okay 18 19 20 somewhere in there
when does hand size matter with these
quarterbacks
great question dan context is everything
kenny pickett's had 27 fumbles and lost
11. it's meaningful with him if we're
talking about a guy that never had any
fumbles he could have six inch hands it
wouldn't matter but the fact that they
were sub nine inches and he's had ball
security now with that said if you and i
were running team we could still take
him but we'd be sitting there talking
about what's our plan for him what's the
ball security drills like how are we
going to work on this every player has
strengths and weaknesses but his hand
side is meaningful because he's had 27
fumbles in his career
what's the uh 33 team is that you're
teaching at columbia is that part of
that well yeah correctly you're slightly
different so the 33rd team is a bunch of
coaches like doug peterson dan quinn
that when they were with the team they
wanted to stay current and we have some
rock star
grad students that are supporting them
and we're just putting out free content
to the world that's sort of like
just looking at things from behind the
curtain we had brian schottenheimer just
write an article about what it's like to
be a quarterback coach at the combine we
had bill pulling write an article why he
hired tony dungy and it's just trying to
bring people behind the scenes it's
3013.com
and we have a free newsletter
but you're also teaching a course at
columbia university aren't you
i i am so i squeeze that in between my
responsibilities at espn so we do that
uh every tuesday in the fall and that's
the business of the nfl and um it's
great there's so much to talk about uh
around the league and uh there's a whole
bunch of grass students that are way
smarter than their professors so i think
i learned as much from them as they
learned from me help me understand this
sam how the north carolina quarterback
goes in for his interview with the
eagles and soon as he walks in they have
him do papa shot
what
what are you looking for there uh
if you're the eagles
com competitors you know like pete
carroll is really known for that like
pete in his team meetings will have an
offensive guy against a defensive guy
and he wants them competing at
everything and i think
you're looking you know coach parcells
has a great expression dan like you want
to battlefield commander as a
quarterback so does he hit the shot does
he command the room does he handle
adversity i can't tell you how many
times dan over the years in indy we have
taken quarterbacks off our board where
we would show some interceptions and we
would say hey take us through that play
and they would blame the play call they
blame the receiver
and like they're they're off the board
so you learn a lot about people that way
what if they're right
what if their assessment of the play was
it was a bad call oh you know
that receiver made the wrong pattern
yeah no that's fair damn but you're
going to be alan rogers or patrick
mahomes and have a little equity in that
conversation first
you don't think you don't think aaron
rodgers would blame the play calling or
uh his wide receiver coming out of cal
he would 100
but you know it's interesting to say
that aaron rodgers slid for a lot of
reasons back in the day and
we didn't interview him when he came out
but i'll tell you like
intangibles matter especially what was
the criticism of rogers and why he he
fell to the first and you know he was a
junior college transfer first of all you
know he was not and now look nowadays
that wouldn't matter at all back then
there was all sorts of studies about
being a 30 40 game starter um and i
think there were some questions about
you know leadership and
look at the time the irony was you know
alex smith went one and mike mccarthy
was the offensive coordinator of the
49ers mike nolan was the head coach they
picked alex smith over aaron rodgers
mccarthy becomes the head coach of the
packers and the rest is history so the
ultimate irony was if mccarthy as the
offensive coordinator of the 49ers had
selected aaron rodgers think about how
much history would have been different
for mike nolan at the time aaron rodgers
and mccarthy and green bay
great stuff as always mike we appreciate
your time thank you you make us smarter
yeah i appreciate it uh big fan of your
show and really appreciate you having me
that's mike tannenbaum the espn nfl
front office insider former jets gm